I would a kill for a Barbie growing up
my parents wouldn't buy us any cool toys
they bought us board game even the names
of board games are a bummer
sorry trouble operation and the saddest
of all
life what kind of Twisted messed up game
for a kid is life you play games to
escape life not Dive Right In you got a
kid outdoors in the sunshine playing
with his friends you're going to drag
him inside to play a game about mortgage
and divorce Ah that's too real pick a
card give me what'd you get I got
herpes hey roll the dice oh say you put
out a tweet 10 years ago came back to
Haun your
fire damn life sucks hate a board game
remember clue I hated clue Professor
plum in the study with the Candlestick
that's not relatable who's dying from a
Candlestick you got to update that stuff
make it stuff that kills people now
peanuts gender reveal
party